- I should probably not tell this story,
but this is who I am.
(upbeat music)
I'm looking forward to actually having
more guests back, like in person.
I feel like I got to talk
to a lot of people in second season
that maybe wouldn't have
been able to come to the show
or don't really travel,
but like, I got to talk to Michael Douglas
and Catherine Zeta-Jones in Spain.
I got to talk to Julie Andrews.
I got to talk to all
these people that I love
that maybe wouldn't have come on the show,
maybe in second season,
because of whatever reason,
and because of how we were remote,
I got to really connect
with a lot of people
that maybe wouldn't have
come on the show before.
So it was really cool to
kinda meet those people
and establish those relationships,
and now maybe get to have them in person,
because like, do I wanna hug Julie Andrews
like an awkward amount of time?
Yes, I do.
I think I'm excited to have
people that I had over like,
whatever on the screen.
I'm excited to have them
back here in person.
That's kind of what
I'm super stoked about,
and I'm excited about Kellyokes
again, I like doing them.
And by the end of last season I was like,
"Oh my God," my brain was exploding,
'cause we've done so many,
there's a hundred and
eighty every season y'all,
it's a lot of songs.
But I think I've had enough of a break
to where I'm like stoked again, so...
(upbeat music)
So I think this season we
already have a ton picked
for next season,
but we had a lot of requests
for people to actually
have me sing my songs,
and I think that's
weird, because it's vain.
And like I'm gonna open
the show with my song,
and like if it's not
a new song coming out.
But I listened,
so my musical director,
Jason, and I were talking
and we might do...
We're gonna sprinkle in
some of my like songs
that people maybe wanna hear
that haven't heard in a while
because I haven't been doing shows.
We're gonna sprinkle it in and do...
How they win me over is
we're gonna twist it up.
We're gonna do them a little differently,
than maybe you've heard them before.
So that will be exciting
and kinda cool to do.
And we already have a
huge list of Kellyokes
that we've picked several that
we're gonna kinda change up.
I like doing that, we can't do it
for all hundred and eighty
'cause there's not enough time,
but I like when we have the
time to really take a song
and like flip it a little bit.
But yeah, I'm excited about Kellyokes.
(upbeat music)
I should probably not tell this story,
but this is who I am.
One of the funniest things that's happened
on this show this far, in any season,
was I was doing a juice
cleanse and... (laughs)
And, I think it was Whitney
Cummings who was there.
And I think it was Whitney
Cummings' worst time.
And I literally looked at her and I go,
"Yeah," I was like, "I
just, I'll be right back."
And then I like ran to the bathroom,
and then I came back and I
just broke it down for Whitney.
I felt like we could be
those girls, and I was like,
"Whoa! I had to go because
I'm choosing work time
to do a juice cleanse apparently,
and it caught up with me.
And so, (bleeping) happens."
(laughs)
(crowd laughs)
And that was pretty much
the most memorable...
Other than that, there
was one time we learned...
This is also one I shouldn't probably say.
Sometimes we have to do the Kellyokes last
because of whatever timing
or a guest needs to go,
something happens, so
we have to do it last.
Well, everyone sells an alcohol, right,
like everyone that comes on here,
and I don't wanna lie so like, I try it,
so I'm like, and it's
usually a little bit,
so it's like fine.
This particular day I did not remember
that I had not had dinner the night before
because of kid stuff,
whatever, running around.
And I had not had breakfast,
and obviously not lunch,
'cause it was kind of lunchtime,
we were wrapping up the show,
I was about to have lunch.
So I didn't have food, and I was trying...
I can't even remember
whose alcohol it was,
but I'll tell you what (laughs)
I know it was a Toni Braxton song,
and it was "You mean
the world to me" maybe,
I don't know which one it was.
It was like climbing Mount
Everest to get that song.
It had affected me till I was like,
"Oh my God, I can't."
I felt like I was at a karaoke bar,
and I'd had a couple.
And I, which is not great.
And it took me a minute
to get that Kellyoke done,
and I think we've realized, one,
try and get Kellyokes done
at the very beginning.
And then two, maybe just take a tiny sip,
to be honest and say,
you either liked or disliked
their alcohol flavor, or,
eat beforehand.
So that was fun too, but "You
mean the world", it was...
I was sweating. It was sad. (laughs)
It was sad. But we got it done.
I think it was Dwayne Johnson's tequila,
which I'm gonna be honest
with you, is so good.
To Dwayne Johnson
everybody! (crowd cheers)
It was a really big
shock, and then it's like,
I'm on camera, I'm like,
we'll I don't wanna look weak.
So I'm like, "I can do this,"
and then I was like "Whoa."
(upbeat music)
I mean, I think everyone knows
the answer to this question,
but I'm kind of half and half,
because I'm nervous about it.
But I think a dream surprise for me,
I know they surprised me
last year with Patty Griffin,
which I was floored, I
was like, there's a...
She has a doppelganger.
The amount of time it
took me to figure out
it was actually Patty Griffin.
I was like, "What?"
First of all, holy (bleep)! Holy (bleep)!
I was like, she looks
exactly like Patty Griffin!
(screams)
Like I was freaking out.
I think that, yeah,
the person who would probably
freak me out the most
would probably be Meryl Streep,
but here's the thing,
I'm on the fence over that really,
'cause like you know when
you love someone so much
and you're just so,
you adore them so much that you're like,
maybe we shouldn't ever really...
We met, like quickly on a red carpet,
but I just mean like,
like sit and chat, I don't know,
I think I might be nervous.
Or Julie Andrews in person, what!
I would be really happy about that.
There's a lot of people honestly
I'd be very excited about,
I like a lot of people.
But I think that like ultimate for me,
just because how much I
watch her films and love her,
also it's 'cause,
you know what, y'all,
she's not just a singer,
she's like a dancer, she's
an actor, a singer, a dancer.
Meryl is everything.
Like, not many people are everything.
That's a lot of talent in
one human, just saying.
(upbeat music)
(signal beeps)
(indistinct chatter)
I'm sorry.
It's this one? It's...
You know what is funny?
It's probably not even mine.
(crowd laughs)
I mean it's mine,
I bought it.
(signal beeps)